I'm wondering what the challenge is to
the to the person doing the scoring when
there are subtitles involved and you're
trying to evoke a certain thing out of
us but there is there are these
subtitles we have to work with and work
around I mean never came to my mind but
now that you mentioned for example I
mean I first movie I did with alejandro
gonzález iñárritu amores perros there's
a movie that abuse team here with with
subtitles huh it never really came in in
consideration when I'm doing the music I
am I really think I mean the reason I
choose that particular movie you know
the luima movie it's you know was a
moment also in Argentina where we grew
up in Argentina we had the opportunity
to watch a lot of foreign movies you
know be we watch American movies we
watch foreign movies and that particular
score always you know had a you know a
very big influence in me too I mean I
love Miles Davis I think also once again
it's a use of a very very you know one
instrument and somehow evokes the
displacement of the characters in this
movie and loneliness and the
displacement of the characters in the
movie I I I feel that really music is it
is the emotional connection between the
film and the audience I mean it is what
creates what completes and humanizes the
final finalize the process of humanizing
and identification with the characters
when you're watching a movie I think the
music plays a very important role in the
in that aspect I think I mean there have
been experiments of doing films with no
music and they work I think that the one
of the concepts that you were talking
about which is important is the
manipulative aspect of music I work with
have the blessings of working you know
with people like alejandro gonzález
iñárritu walter salles
Lee and these are the directors that
actually obviously in any art form you
are somehow manipulating right i mean
you're trying to convey something and
trying to transmit something but i think
it's the the subtlety in the art form is
when you really don't know this you are
taking their but without really having
you know being hit with a hammer in your
head you know i mean so m and that's the
same thing happens also with the
melodies I mean what is a good mood
music for a movie music that you and you
go out of the movie theater and you
really don't remember that well but it
really you know served the picture or is
it or there are some melodies that you
go out with that that you know
reverberate with you I think it's a
combination of both but definitely it is
the emotional connection between the
characters and story and the audience